alors voilà depuis la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi
le public américain et le public de
partout sur la planète a pu comprendre
que monsieur trump avait la coved
alors on s'est demandé à ce qu'ils
allaient être très malade
un peu malade pas du tout malade et
quelles seraient les conséquences sur la
campagne électorale américaine pendant
que vous voyez des images en direct du
world trade center doute il va quitter
dans quelques secondes pour retourner à
la maison blanche où il sera quand même
suivi ce qu'on comprend pour l'instant
c'est que les médecins nous ont expliqué
tout à l'heure vers 15 heures que ça va
plutôt bien
il a accès à de la médication que le
commun des mortels n'a pas on va
demander au dr weill dans quelques
secondes
est ce que c'est ça qui peut être
efficace ou tout simplement il n'a pas
développé de complications malgré son
âge 74 ans et le poids parce qu'on
disait depuis vendredi il a toutes les
caractéristiques qui le mène tout droit
vers des complications
ce n'est pas arrivé jusqu'ici raphaël
jacob est avec nous bonsoir raphaël
bonsoir le dr weiss qui a aimablement
accepté d'être avec nous ce soir dr
weiss bonsoir à vous bonsoir je commence
avec vous docteur vexe pas ce qu'on
disait vendredi il a 74 ans il fait de
l'embonpoint
il est vraiment candidat pour des
complications
il semble que non comment vous comprenez
la sq est arrivé en fin de semaine
médicalement
d'abord il faut savoir que c'est pas
tout le monde qui a 74 ans qui veut
avoir des complications il ya un aspect
qui est la génétique qui joue un rôle
très important peut-être que monsieur
trump à la bonne génétique pour ne pas
avoir de grosses complications ont la
vie au québec quand on avait nos
problème dans les ch et celle des c'est
pas toutes les personnes âgées qui était
toujours très malade
on sait que les gens qui on va dire une
origine génétique en tout cas on le
suppose d'europe du nord on le voit en
grande bretagne on voit en scandinavie
on l'a vu dans le nord de l'allemagne
que les gens peut être une maladie moins
sévère c'est une hypothèse expliquerait
peut-être que pourquoi moins de
problèmes dans certains de ces pays là
par rapport à d'autres pays d'europe du
sud c'est peut-être pas toute
l'explication mais peut-être mais
surtout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
monsieur tremblay était probablement
passé très malade mais comme il est
testé quasiment tous les jours
probablement on a rapidement détecté
qu'il était positif et on a décidé de
traiter de façon extrêmement agressif
dès le début et on a donc empêché que la
maladie ne se dégrade il a reçu des
traitements standards comme la
dexaméthasone un antiviral comme le rêve
de sévir et il a reçu aussi molécules
qui est actuellement expérimental mais
ce qu'on appelle un anticorps monoclonal
dans quelque chose de très très
spécifiques et de très très high tech on
va dire qui a permis au virus de ne pas
pouvoir atteindre revenons en arrière la
dexaméthasone c'est ce que tout le monde
a accès à ça lrm des vies on avait
beaucoup d'espoirs et quelques mois est
ce que tout le monde a accès ce qui l'a
reçu alors tout le monde a accès la
dexaméthasone quand on hospitalise un
patient au québec dans un hôpital on va
recevoir de dexaméthasone leur md sévir
en accès aux médicaments le donne de
façon beaucoup plus fréquentes
qu'auparavant on aussi on va donner des
médicaments pour empêcher de faire des
caillots dois te faire des thrombus donc
on va en donner une thérapie anti
thrombotique ce qu'il a reçu également
donc tout ça ça fait partie traitement
standard de tous les patients
hospitalisés au québec
le remdh et sévir s'il ya une indication
au valdonnez dans sin on ne donnera pas
mais la dexaméthasone et l'autre oui par
contre ce qu'il n'a reçu que les autres
ne peuvent pas avoir si ce médicament
fabriqué par la compagnie le généreux
qui éteint ce qu'on appelle un anticorps
monoclonal et est-ce que vous
quoi ça on ne sort jamais c'est ce qui a
fonctionné ou pas ben c'est probablement
un ensemble de facteurs s'est tous mis
ensemble tenez précocément à quelqu'un
qui n'était pas très très malade et qui
est jeune nous n'allons probablement pas
devenir très malade et probablement que
tout fait très rapidement à empêcher les
complications ce que ça nous est il
finalement c'est ce qu'on savait c'est
que plus on traite précocément les gens
de cet âge là avec un cocktail de
médicaments plus la chance de diminuer
cette tempête de cytokines qui va rangs
des gens très malades à la journée 7 à
la journée 10 n'aura pas lieu mais il
faut aussi comprendre que monsieur jobs
on nous a dit que dès vendredi matin il
ne faisait plus de fièvre ce qui était
bon signe
est-ce qui montrait aussi que c'était
quelqu'un qui probablement ne l'est
peut-être pas évolué vers où je dirais
une moto
par ailleurs on l'a vu il n'avait jamais
d'oxygène ou quasiment
et ça aussi c'était un bon signe dès le
début très bien ce qui lui a fait écrire
sur twitter
aujourd'hui on va voir le tweet raphaël
c'est là vous entrez en scène parce que
il ya une dimension politique évidemment
une gigantesque
on est en pleine campagne électorale bon
il dit jacky très bon très bien 18 ans
hélas la phrase importante n'ayez pas
peur de l'aco vide
ne la laissez pas dominer votre vie nous
avons développé sous mon administration
de très bons médicaments etc
je me sens mieux qu'il y avait un tas
quand il dit n'ayez pas peur de la coved
l'est il est en campagne
il repart en campagne et comme il n'a
pas été très malade du bon finalement
rien moi et l'extrême politiquement
patrice pour lui c'est que contrairement
à ce que bien des gens supposés la
semaine dernière lorsqu'on a eu le
diagnostic que saleh le cerveau et
politiquement qu'elle est allée chercher
un énorme capital ou même un modèle ce
capital de sympathie avec ça c'est tout
le contraire et c'est tout le contraire
en fait en partie à cause de sortie de
la sorte
et lorsqu'on regarde les sondages qui
sont sortis à l'échelle nationale aux
états unis depuis les 24 dernières
heures
le portrait est très très clair
premièrement la nette majorité des
américains on parle de plus de 60%
d'entre eux blanc mais sans senna on
responsabilise le président chaume pour
s'approprier fac-ci infections donc on
est un sondage par exemple
reuters publié hier matin khider qui
démontrait que c'était à peu près 60 5%
à peu près les deux tiers des américains
qui jugeaient que si dans leur chambre
avait fait preuve de plus de prudence
face aux 40 heures virus il n'aurait
probablement pas été infectés le taux de
désapprobation du président pour tous
qui la pandémie atteint un taux record
donc aujourd'hui dans un autre sondage
publié par sionnel de 60%
donc c'est très très loin d'elle
services à des gallois pas du tout au
contraire ça ne l'aide pas d'autant
qu'on a vu toutes ces images depuis
plusieurs jours de réunions dans le rose
garden où les gens étaient très près pas
de masquer mes docteurs vous quand vous
y quand vous lisez le président
américain quand même pas le voisin
laisse quand même quelqu'un d'important
qui dit n'ayez pas peur de la coved
comment vous réagissez
écoutez c'est sûr que le message qui est
envoyé surtout pour les gens de son
groupe d'âge peut comprendre que des
fois les gens qui sont jeunes peuvent
dire ces peuples
c'est beaucoup moins grave
personnellement si vous avez 30 ans ça
peut être plus grave
d'un aspect de santé publique si vous
avez des gens à risque autour de vous
mais pour quelqu'un de son âge c'est
clair que s'il faut quand même s'en
méfier il est quand même allé à
l'hôpital il a été chanceux et tant
mieux pour lui mais on a vu d'autres
chefs d'état qui ont été hospitalisés on
a vu le premier ministre britannique qui
a été hospitalisé qui est plus jeune que
le président de chambre qui est même
passé quelques temps soins intensifs
alors non c'est une maladie qu'il faut
quand même pas à minimiser
écoutez ce qui va quand même arriver
c'est que il sera peut-être courageux
puis voudra faire sa campagne quand même
mais après avoir une affection à l'aco
vite quand on a même jeune mais quand on
a dans 74 ans encore plus ils risquent
d'être fatigué c'est à dire qu'il ya une
espèce de fatigue comme lorsqu'on fring
pneumonie et serra qui fait que les gens
ne sont pas à 100% de leur potentiel en
quelques semaines qui adore ça aussi je
veux dire je sais pas comment il se sent
mais c'est clair il faut pas minimiser
quand même là qu vide parce que et
écouter il a quand même été malade et il
s'en est bien sorti en tron n'était pas
très malade mais on lui a donné beaucoup
de traitements très rapidement et ça a
probablement a eu un impact sur
l'évolution ultérieure
des choses parce que raphaël il a là
dessus comme choisissons au coeur parce
que hier il avait twitté quelque chose
de très différent il avait dit j'ai
appris beaucoup
on se demandait s'il n'allait pas faire
preuve d'humilité ce qui est rare en
disant bombe dans le fond ils souhaitent
prenons au sérieux s'il vous plaît
mesdames et messieurs protégez vous
restez à deux mètres parce que ça peut
être très grave
on voit qu'il revient sur son camp
plutôt des gens qui disent il faut
repartir au plus vite l'économie arrêter
de fermer tout comme il l'a dit en débat
à baden là vous vous avez votre gros
masques j'avais trop peur quoi juste
pour revenir rapidement sur les propos
de doctorat et ce sans aller sur le
terrain médical le jeu lui laisser
peut-être peut-être préciser une chose
c'est qu'on n'est pas sûr à 100% encore
à ce jour ce que le président reçus en
apport reçu comme traitement et ça fait
partie de la contreverse qu'on a
présentement aux états unis parce que
lorsqu'on regarde ce que son médecin à
10 et surtout ce qu'il n'a pas voulu
dire à la fois samedi encore cet après
midi on lui a posé des questions très
directes à répétition il n'a pas voulu
dire explicitement ce que le président
avait reçu à plusieurs égards donc ceci
alimente beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'interrogations donc je voulais quand
même de nuances widdowson de
transparence qu'on a noté même au
contraire le médecin s'est même excusé
on a induit en erreur les journées est
la toute première conférence de presse
oui exact je pense d une fois que ça
c'est dit au niveau politique ya je
crois une façon raisonnable et
rationnelle de d'avoir des dons
désaccord par rapport à comment adresser
la pandémie mais au minimum on mean man
patrice en faisant preuve d'empathie
c'est quelque chose qui manque aux
résidents depuis le début et ça manquait
clairement dans les tweets on va
regarder cette image en direct
masques évidemment parce qu'il est
contagieux encore mais ce drame qui
revient à la maison blanche on a vu il a
exhibé le point entrants continuent le
combat
la question qui se posera ses
pourra-t-il refaire des rallyes comme il
l'a fait la semaine dernière à padre
vais chez ans c'est sûr on va écouter
bon alors il le parle rapport
on verra dernier agen
je pense qu'on lui a dit quand même
parce que hier quand il est allé se
promener en voiture pour saluer les ses
partisans ça n'a pas été très très bien
vu non plus par la communauté médicale
alors oui rapidement chacun d'entre vous
avant de conclure raphaël le reste la
campagne du point évident non c'est pas
évident pour les raisons que dr weiss
évoqué lui-même il ya peine quelques
instants ce qu'on sait par contre allons
dans le peu de ce qu'on sait c'est que
2-1 le débat vis présidentielle qui
était prévu ce mercredi avec monsieur
pence normalement aura lieu et le second
débat présidentiel qui était la source
de tellement de questions qui devraient
mettre en vedette
évidemment le principal intéressé
président chambres le 15 octobre devrait
également aux dernières nouvelles aller
de l'avant dans la mesure où à la fois
monsieur byden ce matin et le président
lui même il ya quelques heures ont tous
les deux indiqué qu'ils souhaitaient et
qu'il prévoyait y participer donc encore
beaucoup de flou mais au moins pour ce
qui est des prochains débats
normalement je devais normalement de
tout ce qu'on a c'est présentement sarr
et le dr weiss un petit mot par ailleurs
sur cette pandémie qui n'arrête plus
mais le cas par jour au québec est ce
que ça c'est un chef que vous regardez
aussi beaucoup plus encore une fois les
hospitalisations qui vous inquiète
ça augmente jour après jour pas des gros
gros chiffres mais quand même jour après
jour sa maman m'a écouté on est à plus
de 1000 cas depuis plusieurs jours c'est
ça qu'on vient des hospitalisations
s'attend pas à avoir un système déportés
mais encore une fois ce qu'on veut avoir
on veut avoir un système cette fois ci
qui fonctionne pour le nom qu vide c'est
à dire de continuer à opérer les gens à
traiter les cancers à s'occuper de
l'ensemble la population québécoise tout
en ayant la capacité de traiter les
patients qu'ovide moins nombreux
heureusement durant la première vague
qu'on risque d'hospitaliser donc il faut
voir que la dynamique n'est pas tout à
fait la même par contre il ya des choses
très différentes la population affectée
beaucoup plus jeune elle est beaucoup
plus mobile elle touche beaucoup plus de
régions au québec donc c'est si vous
voulez une guerre est beaucoup plus
étendu que centré sur l'île de montréal
avec les chsct
donc ça demande une approche qui est
très différente de la première vague et
oui le nombre de cas augmente et on le
voit sa des impacts socio économie
des impacts sur l'ensemble de la société
québécoise et donc c'est un effort
constant de tout ce qu'il faut faire
pour essayer de maîtriser cette partie
là pour pas qu'on soit pris dans ce
quart-temps de confinement pendant très
longtemps
souhaitons la merci à vous deux très
apprécié merci au revoir
roy